d'année en année les mêmes reportages
sur les conditions de vie déplorables
dans les réserves
on a le sentiment que rien ne change que
rien ne bouge et on ne peut pas parler
d' inégalités socio économique au canada
sans parler des autochtones ce sont en
fait les grands laissés-pour-compte du
partage de la richesse au pays
regardez ces chiffres 40% des enfants
autochtones vivent dans la pauvreté au
canada
c'est trois fois plus que la moyenne
nationale le taux de suicide est cinq à
six fois plus élevé chez les jeunes des
premières nations que chez les non
autochtones et environ 70 % les jeunes
autochtones qui étudient dans les
réserves ne terminerons jamais leurs
études secondaires
pour nous en parler j'ai joint plus tôt
à yellowknife dans les territoires du
nord-ouest mary wilson
elle a été commissaire sur la commission
de vérité et réconciliation sur les
pensionnats le docteur madame oleson
bonjour bonjour moi d'aller vers le haut
madame oleson quand on regarde ces
chiffres on peut se demander comment
c'est encore possible en 2015 qu'un
enfant autochtone n'est pas les mêmes
chances dans ce pays qu un enfant non
autochtones oui bah c'est une très belle
question qui est ce une question qui
nous appartient à nous tous et mais
justement au cours de ces dernières six
années qu'on a fait la commission de
vérité et réconciliation on a bien
entendu les pourquoi de tout ça les
liens qui a justement entre l'expérience
des pensionnats qui ont vécu un très
grand nombre d'autochtones au canada et
les conséquences le legs aujourd'hui
c'est un lien direct
oui un lien direct est aussi indirect
aussi parce qu'une chose qu'on a bien et
boire a appris c'est que les choses que
les gens à appuyer vécu au pensionnat
ils ont transféré sa aux prochaines
générations
alors on a aussi des jeunes et les
petits-enfants aussi qui ont vécu les
conséquences de tout ça que ça soit
manque de capacité des parents que ça
soit
en haut un niveau très bas d'éducation
que ça soit le fait d'avoir des réserves
très éloignés des possibilités d'emploi
et puis aussi la question de la qualité
l'éducation qu'ils ont reçue alors mais
l'autre chose très important le fait de
dénis l'éducation je disais toujours que
khartoum sous forme laverty à dire avec
que je lis des l'éducation parce que ce
qu' ils la plupart vécu cette époque
quelque chose de très positif dans
plusieurs cas donc il ya beaucoup de
records pas faire quand vous avez remis
votre rapport on avait le sentiment
qu'il y avait une prise de conscience
que les gouvernements ne pourrait pas
ignorer ce qui s'était passé mais là on
est plusieurs mois plus tard on est en
campagne électorale et on entend très
peu parler des questions autochtones ce
n'est pas un enjeu électoral et vous
déçu ben c'est à but que s'est pas
encore rendu ces élections là il reste
encore le temps et oui justement c'est
une question aux citoyens qui se lève à
haute voix pour dire que les choses
qu'on a appuyé au cours des six
dernières années
il faut qu'on en parle qu'on faut qu'on
insiste que ceux qui veulent se faire
élire par les gens du canada puisse
savoir c'est quoi la position de leur
parti politique
c'est quoi les clients luther qui touche
à la question relation autochtones et
non autochtones
quels sont les théories talent comme
pour égaliser les choses mais s'il y
avait une priorité pour commencer à
améliorer les choses qu est ce que ca
devrait être d'après vous pas une
question de d'améliorer de choses du
coup mais pour être certain que ça finit
pas les tentatives et je dirais je fais
attention à l'appel à l'actionnement 53
de nos 80 14 appel à l'action
ce ça qui fait appel à la création d'un
conseil national de réconciliation
ça serait comme une agence indépendant
du vermont mais qui aurait comme l'a
justement deux choses très important
premièrement faire attention aux autres
appel à l'action pour certains qui a du
progrès là-dessus sur les autres mais
aussi pour faire de sorte qu'ils
commencent à avoir un reportage annuelle
nationale
à voir est-ce qu'on fait du progrès en
ce qui concerne l'écart entre les
autochtones et les non autochtones
j'ai fixé des objectifs et aux fonds
faire un rapport annuel sur ce qu'il
change et ce qu'il ne change pas ou
alors pour voir si on fait du progrès si
on commence vraiment à être le pays qui
se proclame être est ce que vous pensez
que de notre vivant madame oleson vous
et moi on va voir des changements mais
on a fait un grand travail grâce aux
survivants des pensionnats et nous les
commissaires on a fait de notre mieux à
parce que c'est parce que t'es pas une
question limité on a eu l'expérience de
7000 personnes c'est beaucoup et puis on
a offert si je peux le dire comme une
nouvelle recette à savoir quoi faire
cette recette c'est un commencement là
on sait très bien que la réconciliation
ça va prend très longtemps mais il faut
commencer les 94 appel à l'action sa
dame comme une recette à savoir où
commencer pour que les choses commencent
à changer et je pense que c'est à nous
tous de réagir c'est à nous tous
d'assister au gouvernement qu'il
réagisse de même alors on va souhaiter
que tout le monde lisent ces
recommandations merci beaucoup à la
volée sans merci au bout